your lyrics in in the song about I'm up
all night you know and worried about my
body type yes yes how do you do it I
think um hearing people when I talk
about like my mental health or my body
positivity they're like same they're
like you say a lot of the things that I
feel but I'm too too scared to say out
loud and I wanted to give a voice to
that in my music because I need it for
myself and and now with this album it's
with motherhood it's with the mom guilt
of working so much it's with posting
things that are only perfect and not
posting like me sobbing because I don't
take pictures when I cry Chris
um but like just like I didn't want
people to think my I would get
interviewed all the time and they're
like you're a superwoman everything's
great you you love your body you're so
confident I'm like oh no I do all this
because I don't feel those things you
know I'm working every day I'm trying to
better myself and trying to love myself
more and that's what these songs are
about